Hillary Clinton she was interviewed by
those fine people over at Fox News ooo
scary right she sat in between
greta van susteren on one side
Brett Baer on the other she got pretty
severe whiplash from the questioning of
course
literally half of it was about Benghazi have you heard there some kinda
situation the republicans are all gone
crazy about
let's take a look my own assessment
careened from
you know the video had something to do
with that the video had nothing to do
with it may have affected some people it
didn't affect
other people and I think the the
conclusion to draw
because we were not just monitoring what
was happening in Benghazi
wanted began to unfold but remember we
had a very dangerous
assault on our embassy in Cairo that
same day
which was clearly linked to that video
so I was trying to make sense of it
and you know I think that be
investigations that have been carried
out
basically conclude we can't say that
everybody was influencing we can say
everybody wasn't
but what the intelligence community said
was spontaneous protests and that is
what
at the time they thought okay so
actually she did what
lot of politicians issue really say
anything we sorta knew we kinda didn't
know I we did the best we could but I
actually
pretty much think that's the truth I
don't think they intentionally
try to get these people killed like and
I think they probably did the best they
could to secure our embassy in our
people their
I'm so without getting into the
nitty-gritty a ban gai Zhi which no one
seems to know the truth
about with a do questions like this on
Fox News
the what's the goal is to go to just
keep hitting the bases go to change any
did like
to she thinks she's changing anyone's
mind with an answer like that this box
think they're change I did load
like the bigger sorta media question
about it well first can I just say the
girl looks good in royal blue
they recall that rico greater choice for
her better waiting I'm a real democrat
for killari
Joel town yet read by the way danger 0
own
yeah thank you I i think thats a fair
question because when you're
invited onto a show present company
excluded
I think the point is to either you know
pay you know corner make you look stupid
or get you to say something completely
outrageous that you never want to say
I think her whole job which I think she
did a great job that
was just taking the fuel on the fire
quelling if it issued a little double
talking with super vague
I think she did what she was supposed to
do right so is that their purpose they
bring her on there they know she's not
gonna say anything and that's pretty
much what she did we sorta knew we
didn't know about a lot but it's a fair
question
you're going to ask in the they want the
kinda pope the bear little bit India
what her reaction I think they honestly
do want something that they can
you know put on a headline if they all
look at hillary seeded this and they
might even try to spend something that
she did say
but like you said she played it safe and
it was babe I think a lot of times in
politics you have to keep in Vegas when
you say something
and you kind of have to go back on that
all my got the wall come get yeah
crashing down on a bad having to tell
the truth and say what you actually
believe people would
people would freak out this isn't just
some random woman I mean this is
somebody who's going to be
running for president presumably the
thirty his band obviously super
connected to the Obama White House
because she works for an
so what I think expected to say right so
the so that I think do you think this is
more about them attacking
Obama or attacking her is this there
preemption on 26 feel like we gotta keep
this thing going
we know Obama out no matter what so
forget it let's just keep the pressure
on her why not double down
I mean if they are it doesn't matter it
either if they're trying to get
get Obama presently or get her for the
future they win either way
yeah are in 20 ml I mean it's what's
this I don't be a wimp the private kinda
like their MO that's what they did
so speaking of the remote so let's get
away from a guy the I think that's the
interesting thing here is that everyone
was framing this as hillary's going up
box news it's so scary
but in a weird way isn't that a
condemnation in that no defensive backs
news
but is there a condemnation of the rest
of our media good the implication is
well there is a media love their
big ever softball questions all the time
but now she's going to a party that is
really scary
and actually be watching interview I
still think wasn't that scary there was
nothing particularly
a you know pointing yeah it was pretty
tame so is it a bigger condemnation of
the media
that we thought we had one hell is that
supposed to be the scary one for
democrats
I think this historically they have been
the assholes up to me
yeah I mean that's what they know they
kinda set themselves up that way so that
now we're just thought cartons they all
five newsletters blogs that we watch it
it's pretty tame
but we're still gonna be like daughter
she's gonna five loses
just the history and what they've done
yeah they don't that will for themselves
so it's not like we're all
pouncing on them for no reason great if
you wanna be sent a shot beat with a
shot but don't be mad when people assume
that's what you're gonna do again
and I will say I don't think the rest
the media gives a soft ball questions I
think they
they asked the pertinent questions but
they're not coming from a vicious
malicious
angle and I think in the past maybe not
with this interview but in fact that the
boxes that
yet so we've got a budget stories on her
and I absolutely can't
supporter I just don't think we need
political dynasties her husband was
president
I think knowing my family's been
president I think if you someone in your
family the president's are you don't get
to be president but I got
I don't have car UN concert tickets if
you're that he really works for
where you live yeah run yeah
but doesn't think it look at it now
great now I'm really right now
okay I I'm so I so I'm just completely
get there because I just do I just think
we need to freshen people this is just
me more the same
where you george bush had his son do it
like I just don't think already people
are saying that the
Michelle Obama might run for Senate inge
in the Illinois
let's just admit it and with gotta let
go by quick but for
yeah exactly I think everybody yeah well
so about it is as women because you are
women so they must represent all women
that our
rather women do you are you more
inclined
to vote for her
I'm gonna be honest yes yeah and I'm I'm
I didn't vote for Obama
just because he was black but hey I'm
not gonna lie that was a part of it is
like
you want that as after I won t you want
that the woman I want to see our in the
white house and I know
what we say about you know the same ol
rigmarole but you also want someone you
can trust
and so because she's been and AM because
I love clinton at the president
I'm more inclined to say okay she's a
woman she understands that
and she knowles the game she knows these
people as I just trust or a little bit
more I don't want some guy I've never
heard of before
come in and buy ball save the day I
don't think that's what I hear you and
in a weird way I would be more inclined
to vote for bill again so I guess that
take a little
but I wake me up before what do you
think that would push you a little bit
honestly I I don't know why
like if I'm saying this because I'm
exhausted not four hours sleep because I
cap situation those dealing with or
because they really believe I don't know
but at this moment I really feel like
that stuff can't matter can't matter if
she's a woman it can't matter
it it just can't yeah though I am NOT
I don't wanna this just completely
counter out the like bukar are
because yeah she would be part of this
dynasty and i cant say will
it doesn't matter what she stands for I
wanna supporter because she's one and I
just
I maybe there's a party that does feel
that way I don't know I don't think so
though I just
I can't have those be the reason yeah
for me